[Música]
quais suplementos e fitoterápicos para
melhorar a circulação dos membros
inferiores Então essa circulação dos
membros inferiores é fundamental pra
saúde geral do corpo ajuda a suprir as
células de oxigênio e nutrientes quando
a circulação está comprometida ela pode
levar a sintomas como dor fadiga frieza
formigamento nos pés e pernas então para
melhorar a circulação nos membros
inferiores tem vários suplementos terá
que podem ser úteis o caso do omega-3
que é antiinflamatório reduz a
inflamação e aumenta a flexibilidade dos
vasos sanguíneos a vitamina C também que
é antioxidante é muito importante pra
saúde do colágeno isso vai ajudar na
saúde dos vasos sanguíneos o extrato de
ginobili Boo ajuda a vimpocetina também
ajuda são ervas vasodilatadoras podem
ajudar a dilatar os vasos sanguíneos
melhorar a circulação também é o caso da
natoquinase que é um agente
anticoagulante natural e o picnogenol
Eles são muito benéficos na sua
capacidade de melhorar a circulação
periférica então é importante ter uma
dieta rica em frutas vegetais grãos
integrais proteínas gorduras saudáveis e
uma rotina regular de exercícios como
caminhar andar de bicicleta isso vai
contribuir também para aumentar a
circulação sanguínea parar de fumar é
fundamental reduzir o consumo de álcool
e manter um peso saudável também são
abitos que vão ajudar bastante na saúde
cardiovas muscular